ayant ce bon soir clément gignac bonsoir
serge godin de cgi proposé 100 %
subvention salariale probablement pour
arriver à ce sens à ce 75% finalement
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
mesure de subventions salariales
en fait il faut que dépenser que on
écoute et des entreprises
c'est une crise sans précédent quand
jamais vue puis oui on venait en aide
aux travailleurs mais ce que ces
entreprises le sera encore au doute au
moins d'ici donc on se devait de faire
deux poids et le jeu transco fait des
roms comme ans était inquiet que les
machines au niveau de l'assurance emploi
est une star du revenu pourraient même
pas dire la rescousse donc on va pas de
chance c'est costaud lorsqu'on vient
d'annoncer gérable
on parle de mesures le département s'est
pas encore qui s'avouait prix parce
qu'on parle de petites et moyennes
entreprises
est-ce qu'on définit comme une
entreprise de 100 employés - ce qui est
à peu près 50% des emplois au canada où
500 employés - ce qui est 80% des
emplois donc ça va se promener entre un
coût mensuel de 30 à 50 médias n'est pas
la même définition mais je pense que
monsieur trudeau veut se montrer
généreux donc moi je matin là que ça
ressemble beaucoup à ce que monsieur
gaudin proposé mais que font les
entreprises vont payer les employés ils
vont être compensé à hauteur de 75% et
en plus de ça on ajoute des prêts
bancaires sans intérêt pour les pme
jusqu'à 40000 dollars
oui et puis si dans le fond le vous
allez peut-être même avoir un timide
n'avait pas remboursé sur ces sites
on s'assure il parce que vous savez si
des caisses et des banques sont prêts de
leurs filiales
on parle des très petites entreprises
les restaurants eux ils ont besoin de
liquidités à court terme donc à ce
moment-là on avance d'argent donc
là-dessus gerald que des trucs qui coûte
2 kw est au niveau budgétaire comme la
subvention c'était sur sa cote de coin
alors qu'un prêt ça n'impacte pas de
déficit
donc quand on voit toutes aimées des ce
aujourd'hui on annonçait pour 35
milliards de liquidités parce qu'on va
reporter les accords pour la payer la
tps ce genre de truc là des liquidités
mais ce qui va coûter au plan budgétaire
c'est la subvention in elle va essayer
en 30 et 50 milliards par mois
des panneaux m
quand les gens vont retourner à
l'envoyeur et là avec l'assurance emploi
avec la prestation d'urgence ou six ans
vient en avril est-ce qu'on couvre tout
est ce que tout le monde est couvert
c'est pas mal de monde découvre
abondamment si vous êtes un étudiant a
gagné moins de 5000 $ l'an dernier
ce n'est pas un débat et du filet mais
peut-être y va d'autres annonces la
semaine prochaine mais disons le cas on
commence vraiment à rassurer parce que
les travailleurs
c'était quand même des mesures assurant
ces personnes qui se marient riche avec
ça au moins peut faire notre épicerie en
plus l'accueil cerf ou du côté de notre
présent terre d'accueil soit lapin
obtenu donner une chance au niveau des
dix spots et mais le style son
entreprise de cabri en danger oui là on
vient vraiment de réversion fort mal et
on la presse a peut-être combien de
temps ça dure que les gens vont rester
chez eux
et là c'est aux pouvoirs publics a
décidé cela que vient changer
l'intervention de la banque du canada
qui baisse son taux directeur pour la
3ème fois au mois de mars
c'est pas tellement la page du tout
parce que personne qui va vous changer
vraiment ses décisions dans ce contexte
d'insécurité pour 50 points de base
c'est surtout ce qui allait avec gérable
on éteint aux papiers commerciaux au
lieu des grandes entreprises qui doit se
financer sur le marché monétaire les 30
90 prochains jours qui avaient pas accès
maintenant il va y avoir accès parce que
là ce moment d'hollywood et des banques
sécurise aussi puisqu'elle cependant on
peut avancer d avancer des montants
sachant que le band qu'un jet en arrière
de ça donc c'est plutôt au maître de lui
j l
dans l'engrenage le cette annonce le
site patins ou de 50 points de base
on sort on se rapproche sérieusement de
tout ce qui est annoncé aux états unis
que ce soit au niveau de la réserve
fédérale ou que ce soit des mesures
budgétaires puisque le 4 on parle de pas
loin de 200 milliards de liquidités de
déficit
c'est à peu près le 1/10 de l'économie
américaine plus et 2008 c'est à peu près
ce qu'on parle un peu plus tôt cette
semaine un déficit pourrait finir entre
150 et 200 milliards
on n'est pas loin de 10% du pib comme
aux états unis à 2200 milliards on est
aussi à peu près à 10% du produit
intérieur brut
oui mais c'est encore
ce sens que c'est non renouvelable pour
90% des mesures de ce que je peux voir
souffler liquide ce disque est une autre
paire de manches et à ce moment là c'est
pas récurrent dans notre record on est
bien moins endettée que des états unis
n'auront de les finances publiques
puisque nous nous avons comme un triple
or ce qui est pas le code et des hauts
pays du g7 donc aujourd'hui le directeur
parlementaire du budget dit baisse de 25
% du pib en variation annualisée dans
son scénario au deuxième trimestre taux
de chômage à 15% au troisième trimestre
est pas mal d'accord avec ça euh ben oui
en fait une hypothèse que c'était
jusqu'au mois de juin les confinements
et tout le we le confinement savoir mais
la reprise de l'activité économique
c'est qu'un mais on sait que monsieur
thuram en fin de semaine voire une
décision importante bougie petit peu
trop haute ou le 12 avril mais si on
s'entendait en abattant le 1er juin et à
ce moment là le défi et qui faisait état
sera peut-être plus faible que ses
dépenses et est ce que on devrait avoir
un revenu minimum garanti une question
plus large que je vous pose clément
parce que le gouvernement intervient
creed sortes de choses pour aider les
gens si tout le monde avait un revenu
minimum garanti comme ça déjà été
proposé est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas une
couverture de base beaucoup plus forte
mais faut rester camper siffler c'est
parce que l'on est par moments de crise
et dans une crise comme celle là à ce
moment il faut que l'état se substitue
au secteur rêver mais vous pensez que si
vous voulez pas voir des déficits
récurrents
vous devez faire bien attention mais
vous savez c'est un peu
l'expérimentation se confectionner et il
y aura un après le
kobe dinin et est-ce qu'on sera de
principe du revenu minimum garanti dans
les prochaines années
c'est un peu trop tôt pour répondre cela
vous rend plus compétitifs par rapport
au jour posé là citoyen ce jour poser la
question un petit conseil en terminant
oui mais je pense que vous savez voir de
nouvelles amies maintenant c'est sans
doute d'autres représentants de la
banque et de la caisse parce qu'il est
tellement chose que fo ferait référence
avant que la caisse ils vont vous aider
et ça vous enlevez du stress ok parfait
on entend ça merci bonne fin de semaine
clément gignac au revoir au plaisir